this is the gate of Europe it gazes
southward from the Italian island of
Lampedusa from here it's 300 kilometers
to Libya the artwork was created in
honor of the migrants who lost their
lives crossing the Mediterranean seeking
European shores at the port there's a
graveyard for their boats these are
fishing boats from Tunisia Libya and
Egypt after having discharged their
human cargo on the island they are now
of rotting on the shores of Lampedusa up
the road from the port there's this
house its owners have decorated the
facade with colorful planks from ships
it's another tribute to the migrants and
here
a man has collected possessions from
aboard the migrant ships there are
photos baby bottles and cigarettes
Giacomo Sveta la Sol built up this
collection over several years he found
the objects both inside the ships and on
the dumping grounds of La Medusa he
wants to help preserve the memory of
those who arrived here doing them
justice by calling the migrants or worse
illegals they're not defined by being
migrants you see they eat listen to
music brush their teeth wear perfume
steadily so believes his collection
makes a political statement about
Europe's policies on migration he hopes
that it will draw attention to why
people make such a perilous journey
politicians have chosen to deal with
migrants coming from a place where
there's war or persecution in this way
they've never tried to regulate migrants
journeys here it is the system that
ensures that these people continue to
arrive illegally transient migrant still
brave that journey but fewer now arrive
in Lampedusa due to the Italian Navy
operation called
mara Nostrum the sea is ours sailors
pick up migrants off the Libyan coast
and then take them directly to the
Italian mainland but locals like Pietro
Bartolo will never forget what happened
here in the past off the shores of the
island when they started the rescue they
found very few of them was still afloat
I remember the first day there were 111
bodies they were lined up here along
this gangway it was truly horrifying
October 3rd 2013
a ship with five hundred migrants on
board capsized off Lampedusa most were
from Eritrea but they were also
Somalians and people from other African
countries on board 366 people drowned
I've never seen anything of that
magnitude 366 dead the scene filled me
with rage they had almost made it here
there were just 200 meters from the
coast you can imagine them gazing out at
the island and thinking about arriving
but they didn't make it here by a few
metres the doctor has set up an art
exhibition here a year after the tragedy
the disaster was a shock for locals and
it ruined lumpy News's reputation for
many Europeans the island will always be
associated with migrants drowning at sea
but many on the island think it's time
to move on John Damiano Lombardo henslin
produces Hotel Association he prefers to
show visitors the other side of the
Mediterranean island is gorgeous here it
boasts every type of fish from great
white sharks to whales dolphins and sea
turtles so this is the other side an
island with so many resources so much
potential you could rebuild the
archipelago's brand on that but for now
blue seas and golden sand are not enough
to lure the tourists 40% fewer are
vacationing here this year the industry
blames the migrant crisis for that
even if it's now playing out far away
from the cliffs of Lampedusa these
visitors aren't here for tourism they're
survivors of the disaster a year ago
they've come from Sweden and Norway
where they now live to remember those
aboard their doomed ship I remember all
at that time at that moment it's bad for
me and I remember all sounds cries
shouts these people's story has defined
an island and has come to symbolize
Europe's migration crisis a year on hope
and despair still mixed together in the
waters off Lampedusa